salveee youtubers
oggi faccio un velocissimo video per dvd
un paio di cose e per la sorpresa che
avevo detto ad alcuni canali fatto
allora purtroppo sono in ritardo con
vedi video e rosso emmy scusa tantissimo
perché el
la registrazione di
delle erbe il cortometraggio su esame
come potete vedere va
avanti ma molto a rilento perché alcuni
video ci mette 20 minuti per estrarle
esco cerco di stare nei dieci minuti di
video per non divide le due parti che mi
secca
e qua ci sono le riprese come potete
vedere scandalo spero si veda da
mappa hypercam 2
here's to the fate con ali green screen
me per quello che ci metto tanto con
questa belen una porcheria allucinante
uno squallore assoluto che alba hot
giusto bene per l'ascolto da
nomen omen
già ho detto
c'è un motivo per cui si chiama scuro
provaccia la mia casa di produzione
alla veloce vi faccio vedere
subito perché ero così voglio farlo
deve avere i giochi a cui gioco io di
sole perchè non ho mai detto ma molti
me lo chiedono
mi consigliano giochi da giocare belli
allora me li faccio vedere ditari
ereditario wall tour che ho preso da
poco di carico tra loro finito tutto
centopercento
e' venuto sto giocando adesso mi amico
che ha venduto la chitarra da poco
quindi
mi sto scialando parecchio
poi io adoro i giochi di ruolo quindi
hai detto mondo che non sarà perfetto
ma mi piace perchè città ci sono tanti
oggetti tante armature tante cose belle
perchè per me il gioco di ruolo il
personaggio deve essere proprio
c'è nella parte principale dopo, sto
ripassando dev'essere caratterizza bile
poco ma tanto c'è oggi d armi c'è tra
quindi
eletrodo sotto quel punto di vista
abbastanza bello
poi siccome ho poco tempo ho avuto la
brillante di di scaricarmi
dracon sei jocuri jeans che
emma dura poco mi hanno detto di dalle
40 le 60 ore quindi ho fatto una cosa
molto intelligente
torchlight un giochino tipo diablo 1 in
3d molto bello
e poi altre vabe diablo 2 classico
diablo 2 centri alte sport tutto le
fortezze ad esempio a quel gioco online
e
leopoldo work as cordialmente gioco con
un mio amico
adamello cello
vi dico prima di tutto vi ringrazio per
tantissime cose
oddio spero di stare i miei
15 minuti ma non credo
fb valitazione canali a 1000 iscritti
1300 39 anche se qua non ho aggiornato
70 unisim opposizione con ip script in
assoluto e ti ringrazio tantissimo il
vivace e tutti se potessi dopo sono
fidanzato e non
la legge non l'ho
vorrei ringraziare in particolare term
il magnifico mangaforever 0
nizza 900 39 federicoooo
212 hanno fatto dei video
in cui mi hanno citato
federico ha fatto una canzone aiuto mi
sparta remix lui ha fatto una recensione
su man-ga e poi dovuto fare un punto se
alimento sulla recensione
perchè a molti non è piaciuta perché
la capa come me mi disegni facciali
cecina mare con la recensione di un
manga l'abilità l'ha fatta come me ea
molti non è piaciuto allora lui ha
dovuto rifare i get fare un altro video
di chiarimenti mi dispiace poverino non
vedo perchè debbano di vedere quelli
youtobe ma lasciate
fare ma perchè dovete fare him
bimbiminchia da
poi mangaforever 0 che ringrazio perchè
lo conduce diciamo e' un mio contatto da
un po'
emblemi casa anche se non un contatto
diretto lui ha fatto un video con i
migliori youtubers italiani ha messo
messe mauil uscire al più make up now
ringrazio tantissimo anche secondo me
non dovevate perchè
non sono a quei livelli loro hanno tipo
le 100 1000 iscritti - 1000
dvd gratis ma non c'era bisogno e anche
them il magnifico quel con la sua porco
xii pradaccio andare
cioè mi ha messo
mi ha citato che vi ringrazio il gatto
però me lo dovete dire
perché questi video li trovo per puro
caso scrivendo yotobi su
su youtube vengono tutti i video in cui
nelle stanze c'è il mio nome alcuni che
non centro niente i bastardi mettono
nelle stanze
non in tv clio make up win uscito famosi
youtube così quando uno scrive quelle
tonon subito bastarde 3 io li ringrazio
lo stesso perchè si mettono all
il mio nome vuol dire che mi considerano
famoso
e io vi ringrazio
il fan club
spacca ecco reticolo arcuri
582 scritti e si è dato una di
discussioni varie quindi vi ringrazio
così un contatto diretto con voi
non avendo più nessun mio contatto di
via msn
posso parlare con voi qui e sul mio
canale 4
poi volevo ringraziare
una persona che non so chi sia se mi
scrivete yotobi che io do you to main
con gaulle correggi col
molto brutto
ma pur ma ti pare che c'è io topi forse
cercavi molto combattuta scritto io come
forse cercavi o
ottobre che è tutt'altra cosa pago
che cazzo di fare
se mi scrivete gli atomi di kitty
via 11 penne ai funghi con alcuni
perchè capita a volte
la mia pagina di nichi clivia e
spettacolo youtube - youtube repubblica
tante tocana recensioni su film sul
disagio che la prima volta che l'ho
visto
avere un infarto mi è venuto un
erezione spettacolare to wow qualcuno ha
fatto
la mia pagina di vicky figli a carico
questa pagina è stata cancellata
apposto l'elenco delle relative
cancellazione degli spostamenti viene
riportato di seguito per informazione
roberto mura che credo sia uno dei
moderatori di ciriè ha cancellato
yotobi per pagina vuota di prova senza
senso
tautologia 1 ita o stupidaggine
io ringrazio che c'ha provato perchè
purtroppo quando c'è scritto chia
tentato di fare questo me lo ringrazio
anche solo per un reciproco
non dovevate che non sono così famosa
alcuni dicono il biondi
ma voi siete impazziti l'unico dio che
ce e quello del video di donload zone e
poi accolto esatto
niente
la cosa principale che volevo dirvi e
conquer 4 aiutino prima che albergo
dividendo parte
voglio fare per ringraziarvi so che non
è molto ma voglio fare un piccolo
concorso voi praticamente faretto una
recensione di un film
squallido mi raccomando che non sia
sto povero tuailait e che tutti mi
dicono dire ci si è non lo recensisco
[ __ ] it e' un film
discreto non è niente di che ma loro
cisco tutti che vogliono che ce ci
scappa
io sono uno di quei pochi a cui è
piaciuto
ma perché news è un film decente neri
che gli attori sono bravi larry
abbastanza carina
e sono tra quei pochi che aspettano
in una quello nuovo
e io sono sapevi sono un per un posto
nuovo per un mezzo sono una ragazza e
quindi mi piace aspetto youtube e new
moon è con me come le ragazzine che si
strappano i capelli quando guardano
robert pattinson mattia
ebay ti devo dire in fretta
e' un voi farete la recensione di un
film
squallido mi raccomando l'importante nn
con due cose dovete seguire 1 potete
farla come volete
però unlock non dovete farla di un film
che ho già fatto
2 è un
%
c'è un limite di tempo
dovete farla
eni
in due settimane
c'è vi do due settimane di tempo
perché mi sembra credo sia abbastanza
se non lo è meno di te
il 21 io chiudo lei iscrizioni allora se
siamo in più di 10
io faccio il concessami -10 dispiace ma
non lo facciamo
troppo pochi quindi dal 22 in poi io
inizierò chiuderò le cose inizierò a
parlare
c'è afa a buttarle
per chi vincerà prendere un video omj
paradiso 1 canto a però mi darà il
video
e lo metterò commento che nel mio
canale non è molto buono se solo per
far per ringraziarvi io faccio così
ho visto che molti fanno recensioni
venuto perché no
potete farlo del film che volete leggere
commenta importante che non l'abbia già
visti
un'altra cosa spero di non uscire egli
non uscire da
lol thank u n'altra ultima cosa vorrei
togliere
è un paio di mie recensioni soprattutto
quella di palermo milano il ritorno
mortal kombat 2 e quelle dei giochi
vecchie
per chi è sono vecchie fanno schifo non
fanno ridere sono veramente stupida
soprattutto quella di milano palermo
fatto delle battute che non so neanche
perchè le abbia fatte forse sul momento
non mi veniva nient'altro di
intelligente
sopratutto quella sull'accento
sicigliano molti me l'hanno criticata e
di giuro avete ragionissimo e mi
dispiace
non so chi
cazzo di battuta sia quella dove dico
che
l'accento di siciliane del bangladesh ma
vi giuro
il barolo più razzista che non l'abbia
mai detta qui non l'ho mai detta blue
giuro
e niente
legge probabilmente tornerò alla fine
di far on più avanti meglio che me ne
faccio del farmaco minuto
rt ringrazio mi raccomando mettete nella
recessione come video di risposta a
questo video
e io nascero' livido di rispondi 100 dvd
disposta aperti così potete mettere
come volete
lo fanno vabe faccio che
link aggiungerli va e meglio
mi raccomando fatele da una parte sola
il pastaio vi ringrazio
se ci sentiamo la prossima i video
arriveranno dal pozzo volta farò una
recensione di un film
vi ringrazio saluto